so there's actually a huge camera at the
end of the Maryland season 3 finale that
you're most likely missed so is denjar
and grogu walk into the bar in the
distance in the background we see no
other than David himself making another
cameo in Star Wars I say another Cameo
who was previously in the same bar in
episode 4 he also made a camera in the
background and yet again we'll see him
here again drinking I think it's very
wholesome that Dave filoni has you know
put himself into these stories given
himself an Easter egg which is himself
because let's be honest he deserves it
and it's great to see his iconic cowboy
hat in Star Wars now but this just makes
me wonder in future episodes of The Man
Lauren or similar shows in the man
reverse will we see just Dave filoni or
other Star Wars creators like John
Favreau just make random background
cameos like this or even given a role in
the show like how John fabric gave
himself a role as Paz rizler but anyway
that's about everything for this video
so let me know what you guys thought
about this episode in the comment
section below I know hope you guys have
a great day thanks for watching